meningitis means the inflammation of the
meninges
question is how meningitis can be
determined meningitis can be caused due
to several organisms like bacteria virus
or even fungus how does a clinician know
which organism has caused the meningitis
in order to know that CSF is drawn from
by lumbar puncture and from CSF
biochemical examinations are performed
clinicians ask is there an infection if
there is an infection if the WBC levels
are elevated
which WBC level is elevated is important
if it is polymorphonuclear cells means
neutrophils then it's most likely
bacterial if it is monocytes most likely
it's viral if it is monocytes and there
is Hypoglycemia most likely it's a
fungal infection both bacterial and
fungal meningitis can lead to reduction
in glucose level but monocyte is
elevated only in fungal meningitis